[Musica]
salve a tutti
e io non so cosa sto dicendo chiaramente
come faccia normalmente vorrei parlare
un po di pigrizia ma assolutamente
periodo che non vorrei neanche parlarne
quindi non so neanche che stiamo facendo
però per dirgli delle cose ha detto cose
molto interessanti e io invece vivo in
questo microcosmo che a spezia faccio
parte di questa di questa popolazione e
ancora diciamo del pleistocene quando
ancora non c'era internet non c'era
niente e vagavo per questa landa
desolata che la spezia dove io ho sempre
detto che l'unica cosa accesa di notte
l'unica luce accesa sinatra spezzerà il
bancomat era la luce del bancomat ora
siamo lì c'era questa cosa del cazzeggio
che la cosa che ci ha fatto un po
sopravvivere tutti perché c'è questa
cosa che dicono riondino per esempio e
paolo rossi chiamano quella cosa chiama
schools che non so che ce l'ha ma che c
è molto fortunato e questo guizzo che in
realtà è un elogio del cazzeggio c'è una
roba che ci ha fatto sopravvivere fuori
dai bar tutta la notte a parlare di
tutto di più di meno da qualsiasi cosa
senza sapere cosa stavamo dicendo e
questa sopravvivenza strana di questi
personaggi che non ci si spostava la
spezia cioè gente tanto spezia finisce
in piazzale c'è il comune cioè migliaia
non esiste un altro pianeta e noi c'è la
gente che per andare a sarzana prendeva
due giorni di ferie e faceva il
tagliando la macchina gente nata
shardana tre volte ha commentato del
fatto l'erasmus e
quindi diciamo un po questa roba qua
questa l'idea di andare fuori dalla
qualcosa di incredibile io mi sono
trovato a prendere il famoso treno che
io trenino mai visti ma ho beccato
questa 127 che ci aveva un regalo della
mia famiglia i miei vivono sempre una
famiglia molto povera e vorrei che mio
figlio continua a servire una famiglia
povera perché amo mantenere tradizioni
ma prevedendo questa casa mi rimangono
scorso colpito però e ho preso questa
127 ho affrontato la cisa e con la cisa
che per noi era ancora un posto
incredibile accesa e quel posto dove
mercati si rifugiavano le donne spezzine
ai tempi che non c'erano i bar quando
giravano solo i marinai le donne
scappavano su per la cisa per il bracco
insieme ai partigiani mentre
rastrellavano i tedeschi e c'era questa
idea di passare la città quale passare
la cisa presa era veramente una specie
di vallata tipo lo hobbit quelle cose lì
c'è una roba strana un po talkin passavi
la non sapevo cosa c'era dietro altro
che terapia testino eravamo avanti e io
prendevo 20 gocce di lexotan la sera e
dieci le davo la macchina da sempre i
dati anche alla macchina perché la
macchina era molto spezzina e quindi
andavano che sabato a milano a
raccontare delle cose sono salite sul
palco come adesso non sapevo cosa dire
ho cominciato racconta delle cose di
famiglia aver cominciato a raccontare
sono talmente pirro che raccontavo le
cose che mi succedevano senza andare a
cercare grandi cose senza neanche
rendermi conto che la gente stava a
sentire le stupidaggini di uno che
raccontava delle stupidaggini in sembra
tanto una banda di così che avevo io
raccontavo le cose di casa perché io
vengo da questa famiglia dove in casa
mia non c'era un libro non c'era niente
ne lavano le scale nella famiglia
abbastanza così però io sono
sopravvissuto come figlio unico tra
l'altro sapete che i figli unici avendo
una madre sono madri di figli unici ma
dentro vergognate a dirlo cioè le madri
che riescono a morire i figlioli perché
sono convinte le madri che ci sia un
video della broncopolmonite che uccide i
bimbi con un viso si sta sempre di
solito sopra lo stile di casa sulla
porta e quando esci se hai una spallina
messa male non è la cameriera di lana
quelle cose lì parte questo dardo
mortale e il bimbo stramazza esattamente
non fa neanche in tempo a trovarsi lì e
la madre fasti che quindi si mentre io
sopravvissuta queste cose qua mentre le
madri da quelli quelli che giocano il
posto di mare se avete che una volta le
madri dicevano che prima di fare il
bagno deve aspettare tre
giorni mia mamma diceva giorno e non
sono mai riuscito a fare il bagno perché
non riuscivo a mangiare per tre giorni
dopo maggiore per forza e faccio alla
donna il servizio a porto venere sono
posti meravigliosi però eravamo così
arrivando lì a milano questo boston
barche si chiamava zelig è praticamente
raccontavo queste cose qua io ho
raccontato le cose che troviamo in casa
facendo diventare una cosa negativa
abbastanza positiva lo dico da ripreso
dai frequentatori di pronto soccorso
l'italia è sembrato assolutamente
ipocondriaco che la prima volta che mi
ha fatto una canna me la sono fatta in
macchina davanti al pronto soccorso per
chavo l'ansia e quindi dicendo queste
cose che poi scoperto una stupidaggine
diventavano battute senza rendermene
conto questa la cosa strana del
cazzeggio del bar e questa roba che 1
celano ce l'ha poi vi dico bravi gli
altri quelli del bar gli autori se ci
arrivo faccio in tempo perché 15 minuti
se solamente un tempo irraggiungibile
però così va a parlare come dice mia
moglie e allora è quindi la prima volta
che mi ha visto in modo ha detto cos'è
una caccia al tesoro ma non voglio
entrare gli argomenti se no diventa una
specie di commedia una roba così però e
arrivando a quanto pare la mia mamma era
una di queste situazioni qua c era una
donnina polverina che avevano un paesino
l'opinione vi racconto il mio papà se
faccio in tempo di cinque terre e
raccontavo queste cose quando mia mamma
veramente erano tutte cose vedere questa
la cosa incredibile na racconta che una
volta mia madre e mio padre ci stavamo
bisticciando una cosa banale stupida
così che una cosa che poi rimanerci male
e diventare del prezzo tutta la vita e
cielo raccontandolo elaborate come se
fosse una sorta di psicanalisi vado in
giro bisogna andare l'anno una lista a
raccontare i fatti miei vado in giro a
conti fatti miei e mi pagano di questa
la cosa incredibile è il car punto a mia
mamma è arrivata ha dato un pugno sul
tavolo e toppa giura di basta quando
fate così mi fate venire un orgasmo
ritorniamo al volo e mi obama ha
guardato metto salute alla finché ci
riconosce ora davanti a riina mandava
servizio in casa di avvocati ingegneri
architetti gente che ha una cultura
diversa assorbirla questi vocabili
mettere nel modo di parlare dando così
origine a famoso slang dalla casalinga
ovvero lo strafalcione a mosca talmente
grossa che per ripeterle ho iscritto mia
mamma la siae ma non è tanto quello però
su altre cose che reggio che sono
incredibile ed a portarci ha fatto un
repertorio sulle cose mia mamma però
l'idea era preso cura del bar perché c'è
questa specie di
serpeggia nella gente che sta seduta a
tutto il giorno e gioca boccette rimane
lì le donne non si sono mai visti
pensiamo ad essere ovipari per anno i
brani che siamo io la prima volta che
sotto una ragazza ho fatto tutto da solo
per anni la pronta una ragazza pensavo
fosse un'orgia in due già mi sembrava
una roba esagerata e allora sentivo
questa che raccontava delle cose che
erano veramente dell'incredibile
e la cosa bella era leggere i giornali
ora questa la cosa incredibile si faceva
a leggere il giornale che il giornale da
una notizia che già è riassunto di una
cosa che è successa
c'è un titolo che riassunto del
riassunto e cioè quello del bar che un
cazzaro incredibile che ha fatto forse
come me l'istituto tecnico che non sa
neanche nulla del mondo è però a questa
roba che leggendo il titolo che l'ha
riassunta riesce a dare a condensare
ancora di più una roba su leggi geniale
tim esempio una volta uno leggeva ci ha
detto furto in casa veltroni la figlia
dormiva abbia detto tutto a suo padre
punto cioè adatto alla roba cioè in un
attimo ha demolito cioè e la capacità di
questa roba di dire delle cose talmente
cattive e talmente feroci talmente per
ma non per cattiveria su una persona è
l'idea del c'è una specie di esercizio
di stile che si fa per sopravvivere in
queste notate spezzine e l'idea era
quella di e una volta mi sono trovato a
quando facevo il programma che la
dandini sapete che per sapere quanti
anni alla dandini io ho fatto fare il
carbonio 14 dal ris di parma però
era abbiamo visto anche lì vengono da
fuori tutte cose se eri importanti la
politica però è venuto fuori il
caseggiato reed a barre della della
provincia che avevo imparato a fare
queste cose da questi qua che erano
molto bravi che non si rendevano conto
che ci sono cose straordinarie
a un certo punto era guardando su
internet e molto per stare sul pezzo
come si diceva a vedere le cose nel
momento quotidiani era uscito fuori che
era morto un signore di 96 anni che
curava tutte le voci dello zingarelli
vocabolario della lingua italiana
io ci ha dato la linea da uno è morto a
stazionare qua perché tabù parlar di
morte in televisione tonini è morto un
signore 96 anni correva tutte le voci
che lo zingarelli emigrato mette allora
io dalle ultime parole sono stati zuppe
zuzzurelloni è una cazzata terribile tra
mi sono trovata avere da 60 anni nuovo
13 e altri due autori gran con me che
hanno questo rose gurs incredibile
e hanno cominciato a fare un mi ha fatto
una gara è diventata una roba che adesso
scopro che anche su internet fan ste
cose non eravamo veramente preistorici
ogni volta che arriva qualcuno c'era
questa corsa chi dava la battuta che non
è contro qualcuno è proprio l'idea di
avere due cosette farci qualcosa cioè
propone quindi esercizio mi ricordo che
era morto foppapedretti che mi sono
prestato da morto foppapedretti silenzio
netto è stato seppellito una bellissima
barak e piegando gli angoli diventa
tavolo dal campeggio cioè e la gente ha
capito che c'era qualcosa che non
quadrava e abbiamo iniziato a darci
dentro come dei cretini però c'è molto
divertiti affrontando il discorso alla
morte come tabuk cioè però eliminando
questa roba terribile un po perché
esorcizzava mo che io sono ipocondriaco
l'ho detto tante volte quindi io mentre
facciamo sta roba abbiamo trovato non
sono volta mi ha chiamato mio amico
fatto in tempo a leggere che era morto
non ricordo gli inventori della moka
bialetti dring subito gli talco fatto mi
ha fregato prepone frazione di secondo
vince morto bialetti vedo benissimo
allora metto le tue parole sono state
e io trovo che sia un intelligenza
talmente veloce in queste cose talmente
incredibile che io nelle mie
stupidaggini che a volte io dico le cose
ma non so cosa dico una battuta molto
bella
un americano che dice prima ero
schizofrenico adesso siamo guariti e
molto bella e io ho questa cioè io
adesso mentre parlo sto pensando a
18.000 cose infatti farfuglio e
strapparlo dico che sono dislessico in
realtà non so cosa sto dicendo che
quando senti volta la vogliamo ha detto
le cose di una volta mi sono trovato a
trento in una serata arco di 30 un sabot
gradire e sono così cazzaro cameraman
della roba che non so poi se funziona o
meno e c'è una specie di vocina che
quella che comanda che dice di la di là
non la voglio dire 9 mentre dico
un'altra cosa magari canto mi sbaglio le
canzoni anche le mie perché numerica
siamo da un'altra detto ha baciato una
ragazza di bolzano era bilingue gelo c'è
gelo totale gelo totale che te lo sapevo
che non dovevo dire che il giorno dopo
ma tale fatto uno per spiegarmi a me la
cazzata cavo that cioè ma guardando bene
succede però è come dire mi dimentico da
dell'alzheimer diventando simbolo però è
quindi l'idea era questa europa ogni
volta che arriva qualcuno a questa gara
stiamo facendo adesso andrà mi ricordo
era morta e come si chiama
carla fracci ho conosciuto cioccolata un
commento mi sono divertito però quindi
non è mai contro anzi questa idea di è
stata questa cosa in salina che ho detto
se n'è andato in punta di piedi questa
mi sembrava anche una battuta seria e
allora era talmente seria che non ce
l'abbiamo messa perché in una specie di
cosa che faccio sugli stadi non si
chiama educazione cinica stato più bello
mio amico ma l'ha mandata metto il cigno
ha detto una volta un po per uno detto
ciò il cineclub da parte c è però
abbiamo trovato nelle cose molto
divertenti straordinarie e alcune cioè
quando mi hanno detto che era morto
l'inventore della brugola della banalità
del mondo e uno mi ha chiamato mi ha
detto la famiglia si è stretta intorno
alla vedova io gli ho detto cioè sono
dei cervelli che andrebbero studiati
andrebbero analizzate io voglio che
dalla storia prende cervelli di questi
del bar gli analisi come franchiste gli
unici però prendo socio livello ci
guardi cosa c'è dentro perché non puoi
dire una roba così quando era morto il
re del botulino
credi che brand si chiamavano roba così
i suoi pazienti non hanno fatto una
piega io sono rimasto sconvolto perché
erano cose geniali ma dette nell'arco di
veramente due secondi questo per dire
che non c'è è una roba che c'hai non so
ce l'hai e la prende poi
profittarne ogni tanto imparare alcune
tecniche
io sto le donne come un diabetico e sto
la meringata in una formula che si
capisce la puoi mettere tante parti però
quella roba lì io la trovo molto
difficile da copiare il vero sono
veramente bravissimi su quelle che una
volta ho trovato le cose politiche da
meravigliosi tipo una volta era morto un
signore che siano a silvio berlusconi di
52 anni un omonimo le due battute
fantastiche sono state per quelli veloci
un morto un omonimo di silvio berlusconi
è scivolato sono stati ghiaccio è morto
e la dimostrazione che il voodoo non è
ancora una scienza esatta questa è stata
la prima cosa e l'altra ancora più
cattiva più fetente più cattiva come il
coso era tipo non so è morto non ho
conosciuto berlusconi fuochino e
comitato trovata il 20 cioè che era è
una cosa da non puoi studiare la
cambridge un'altra parte ciò credo che
spezia di questo questo e quindi ho
trovato questo è bene riportarlo e nel
trovare quasi geniale questa cosa che
uno sta seduto e dice solo cazzate la
trovo fantastica io ho fatto 20 anni da
arsenal e quindi sono abbastanza e
quindi ho fatto anche io le dicevo che
facevo talmente poco che la finanza non
indagava sul secondo lavoro perché non
faccio neanche il primo però ho detto
questo
l'idea è per andare in giro a dire
stupidaggini questa è una cosa che ci
piace e ci raccontiamo è un modo per far
le cose quindi cosa perché dicevo anche
di mia mamma io vivo in questa casa
molto povera io c'ho questi eletti a
ribalta
diciamo questo letto dove io tornavo di
un di notte per non svegliare mio papà
che dormiva in sala perché mi amerà in
camera con mia nonna cena a casa
l'imu ci davano noi di soldi credo
addirittura ci pagavano e enumera meno
di zero la casa quindi la casa 0 1 metro
quadrato e allora io andavo in bagno per
non svegliare mio papà andavo in bagno
di sera di notte a mezzanotte al buio
faceva bp tornavo giorno mi amano
impedirlo perché mi portava a vedere
dove avevo fatto la pipì e la nota non
volevo mentre tornavo c'era questi
questi letti che si praticamente si
chiudeva da soli io faccio parte di quei
generazioni dove ai giardini una volta
si drogavano tutti non mi sono mai fatto
di nulla per col terrore di siringa di
tutto quelle cose lì se avessero fatto
l'eroina tipo hicks vaporub
probabilmente dopo aver provato ma e mi
ricordo che una volta chiedendo i miei
amici dei giardini sta cioè insomma
perché ti droghi mi sono perché vedo
delle cose strane giocata lo viene a
casa mia che ci sono nel muro che mangia
eletti di note le cose meravigliose e
mia mamma era terrorizzata da questa
idea del freddo errato riza talmente del
freddo che mi metteva 3 coperti della
marina militare quelle blu
pesantissime che bucano che sono fatte
di kriptonite non esiste sulla terra
pesano al peso specifico superiore al
piombo pesano talmente tanto ma non
scaldano una mazza questa è la cosa
straordinaria è che me ne vo schiacciato
tipo tartaruga messo un po così cercavo
di muovermi e acer molto a mio papà
metteva due amici due stufe nella nella
sala lia carica velica ricava una con la
legna con l'altra si chiama valgo la
mette li metteva il cherosene e dicendo
una frase tipo fuoco alle micce
si chiudeva in camera per fare perché i
genitori non devono avere un grado in
più sennò se non se non soffrano sta
male i genitori dei poveri sono fatti
così io rimanevo lì così con queste
coperti e così che non potevo muovere la
testa né niente e saliva tutto questa
temperatura 20 gradi 40 80 ci arrivano
la mattina mi alzavo mia mamma vestita
come l'ilva adesso sto romanzando amerà
simile sta roba qua tanto mi andava a
scuola in quinte elementari con i panini
coi muscoli
sott'olio i panini quei fondi fritti e
soprattutto mi dava dei soldi se
prendevo un nuovo con la marsala dentro
sei anni andavo a scuola così non ho mai
capito liberi in tre anni non ho capito
davvero cioè non ero un solo vero in un
limbo strano tutti vestiti di nero
capito sembra aver fatto il ventennio mi
ricordo gente questa cosa n'era una che
diceva delle cose imbriago ma cosa
marsala la mattina una roba da
assistenti sociali avrebbe dovuto
portarmi via però se quelle cose che non
gli andava a scuola dice dario
vergassola dicevo la maestra sì mi
chiama dario vergassola sono quattordici
giorni che non bisogna era abbastanza è
bello perchè dico di cazzate che non ho
mai detto mi vengono basta che c'è un
microfono pensa che cosa strana per me
era un po questa idea dove io arrivavo
fuori e mio papà mi portava con la vespa
a scuola questa è un po la è bello
perché io arrivavo da 110 gradi e fuori
c'era meno 10
io quindi adesso senza scomodare tutta
la famiglia di angela però c'è un
escursione termica di 120 gradi sarebbe
morto armaduk e zanna bianca
chiunque e mio papà mi mettiamo anche i
giornali quali ma lo ricordo che
prendevano fuoco perché era troppo caldo
fumavo facevo due metri e il fuori star
motivo perché chiaramente mi ammalavo il
dio della broncopolmonite da solo che mi
cercava di prendermi lo scandalo mi
hanno arrivava in casa mia ma era un
padre a tali e diceva povero ninì
rivestita un po da social dott.essa
egiziana mi spalmava cioè delle
damigelle di vicks vaporub
però padroni come mai si ammala sempre
sto bimbo e cazzarola colpa delle mamme
e dei figli unici che fa ste cose
rispetto a mio papà per dirvi famosi
treni che si prendono forse non si
prendono il coraggio di andare veramente
a milano per me è stata una roba
incredibile però a mio papà che non
personaggio ma non ne so io ho
conosciuto mio papà grazie al co vide
cioè lo dico perché devo abitava di
fronte a me però non lo sai quelle cose
quando va tutto bene coi tuoi non ci
parli male perché poi quando sei
ragazzino non ci pare una sagra dice
casini quando sei frega niente e ha
sempre guidato la macchina poi certo
punto com chiusi in casa e mi sono
trovato a mio papà io ho conosciuto una
persona che non conoscevo incredibile ci
ho giocato a carte tipo 5 ore cioè a
giocare a scopa cioè il vinceva sempre
lui una volta facevo 7bello micia brink
quello che so io casarola dice sapete
ricordi ci siamo insultati per un po e
poi un giorno mi ha detto che stava
molto bella ma detto perché cinque gare
sono così sono un altro posto di quelli
che sembravano brutti per tutti questa è
un'altra scoperta per il cibo ha la
gente scappava perché pensavano fosse un
posto non salubri una cosa dove stavi
male dove la gente va a scappare vuol
avere la macchina sotto sotto il sedere
quindi l'ideale cinque terre a un altro
modo di capire dove non si costruisce
niente la bellezza è fatta da cose a
volte non portando niente lasciando come
quello che io non mi faccio
bene e allora
in questi o questo minuto e 15 secondi
cercherò di 250 quasi raccontando
ventiquattresimo canto di ulisse e
ritorno però succede questo che mio papà
un giorno portandomi marito di parti a
vedere il mare io l'ho portato a vedere
il mare li abitano in alto sulle cinque
terre stava corniglia per andava su dove
siamo tre zie vestiti di nero coi baffi
dove la strada non ci possano trovare il
mio primato portatile caramelle come se
fossero animali feroci
e la chiudo qua perché tanto mio papà ma
le strisce andava a piedi perché mia
mamma mi mandava di notte a prendere la
legna aiuta perché di notte ma detto
perché di giorno lavoravo sette anni mi
facevano i piedi perché lo scalzo io non
so più cosa dire un certo punto queste
tre zie coi baffi terribili ermini rl
consiglia a un certo punto ho scoperto
che nel de bello gallico parlando degli
apuli liguri cesar ha trovato dei grandi
problemi passando da quelle parti perché
dove dice questa cosa che dice uomini
che sembrano bestie donne che sembrano
uomini erano la rella la coesione
[Applauso]